[Applause]
it surprises me to see with long hair
because I think of you from Game of
Thrones and Queen Cersei with the yeah
is that what you call it the turnip is
that a wig or is that you just cut it
down no it's a wig it's the itch you
turn it oh yeah did you keep the turnip
when I Besant it you burn it i I didn't
they'd sue me but I'd like to you would
oh you hated that thing huh it's no fun
to wear a wig is it yeah I know I'm
wearing one right now yeah I'm actually
wearing two of them right now
great you so when did you finish
shooting Game of Thrones
we finished at the end of last year like
October II the end of last year that was
it for the whole thing or just for your
part of it I was like the 12th one out I
think oh oh that's interesting
yeah that's not giving anything away
twelve of how many of you okay I'm just
dying because it's been too long it's
been like 10 years since the last season
I want to want it I know I want it
already I'm impatient what takes them so
long
oh man you finished it winter was coming
to with her never came you finished it
last year and I guess you got to put the
Dragons in and all that stuff but off
yeah I know it's annoying though so when
you get the scripts or that you get all
the stuff or to get pieces of the
scripts for the final season they they
usually give us all of them and if
anyone says they don't flick to the end
they're lying oh they look to see you I
know we all do that if they made it yes
oh really
I see and then we had a big read-through
so everybody gets it and they get a
little bit of time with it and then
there's a big like table read we didn't
do one until this final season when we
were all in Belfast was that fun to do
that altogether it was really emotional
actually was it yeah d-does anybody is
there a particular actor who really
screws around at the table read you your
the I mean I'm a culprit there's a few
of us interesting yeah
what happens at when you're they say cut
and that's it for you Queen Cersei rap
that's a series wrap what happens at
that moment well I thought I was like
it's been nine years you know I'm it's
been amazing and I'm happy to go and
find new things and and then I knew that
David and Dan our creators were doing
you know speeches and giving everybody
these kind of drawings of the
storyboards and I thought my god I just
suddenly got really emotional at the end
and tried to head down the stairs and
they all rushed up and trap me and then
they gave the speech it was really
moving oh they did yeah that's nice yeah
so they have a speech for each of the
main characters yes yeah and so you're
wondering what they're gonna say about
you very interesting I'm gonna be honest
I'm not rooting for your character I
mean are you you are you rooting for her
someone yeah no I'm hoping that at the
end that somebody is on the Iron Throne
but I don't necessarily want to tell you
it's nothing against you it's where do
you I heard you moved out of LA where
did you move to your hometown I did I
moved back to this small little northern
town where I was raised and bought a big
old like Georgian manor house that was
knackered and that's bad knackered and
had to live with my parents really okay
while it was being fixed yeah for a year
with your parents that is not very Queen
Cersei at all how did that go it was we
still talk okay good
did you feel like you'd reverted back to
like were you in your childhood room yes
I was it was like being Tom Hanks in big
I felt like that like I really in my
body but I was kind of behaving weird to
I mean and I had my two kids but we were
all of drinking age not the children and
that made it better did you behave weird
when you were a teenager living in that
house yeah I mean I was tricky
in what ways I once took boyfriend home
and I was quite young and you know I was
was like can you sleep can you sleep
over and they were like no so I didn't
listen and I kind of like Romeo and
Juliet
open the window I was like climb up the
thing so he climbed up and we read books
and stuff all right yeah then he went
for a wee and my mom was having a wee
and she was naked and he was naked and I
just heard screaming I bet my dad was
like what was your dad naked to was
everyone
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie lena headey
did a big interview about the Game of
Thrones Season 8 finale her rapping
filming some of her favorite scenes and
funny moments from behind the scenes so
we got to break it down we're doing a
new round of that Game of Thrones book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video there's a funny Searcy
connection to that story that she tells
about when she was young and she tried
to bring her boyfriend to her home so
that they could sleep together and they
all found each other naked in the
hallway and were screaming at each other
there was a version of that that
actually happened to Jamie in Cersei
when they were very very young one of
the maids caught them in bed together
and then henceforth they were separated
for the rest of their childhood they put
their new rooms at opposite ends of
Casterly Rock started training Jamie to
become a knight
night and day in training Cersei to
become a lady so they wouldn't have that
much time to spend together the funny
story about the Whig they actually would
sue her in real life if she burned that
because it's really expensive to make
all those props but it does sound like
she in real life hates her wig more than
the character hates Tyrion when she's
actually talking about the ending that
they filmed for her character she says
that they finished in October last year
the interesting thing about that is that
officially principal photography
finished in July of 2018
so that means that all the stuff that
they shot in October are probably a
combination of secret endings for
characters that they wanted to hold off
to the last minute and probably minor
bridge scenes just add context to
different scenes if there are too many
time jumps and it just gets really
confusing in episodes but she's talking
about the paint Hall in Belfast where
their main set has been for Game of
Thrones where their interior sets are
like for the throne room at King's
Landing with the iron throne or Daenerys
throne room at Dragonstone during season
seven like when they shoot all the
interior scenes in the main hall at
Winterfell that's an interior set at the
paint Hall
so all those sets are in proximity to
each other so even if characters are on
opposite ends of Westeros sometimes in
real life the actors are filming scenes
very close to each other even if their
characters aren't interacting in an
episode and even though it sounds like
most of the big characters have their
final scenes on an interior set you know
super secret so that nobody could see
what's happening inside the paint Hall
that are probably a number of them that
died during the major battles which are
all filmed outdoors
in the only real exception to big battle
episodes is when they're filming
Daenerys when she's writing Drogo
that's all green-screen that they do
inside it's the big crowd shots when you
have all the armies running at each
other or standing information that's
done outdoors and then they have that
big quarry set where they film the big
season seven episode six battle that
they turned into the lake they've reused
that a couple times they just turned it
into different sets as they need to any
time they need like a really big outdoor
wintery looking field everybody has a
couple ideas about how the characters go
out but the bridge scenes that they film
usually for context or like the little
finger Aria Sansa storyline imagined
originally if they had not had a scene
where Sansa visibly recognizes little
fingers treachery and then goes and
talks to brand then they kill him off at
the end of the episode anytime there's a
storyline that just flat-out does not
make sense to anyone usually they have
to add like a minor scene where two
characters are talking to each other
it's usually pretty easy to film unless
there was some complete disaster the
first time they filmed a big scene or
they completely changed a script usually
that's what reshoots are for Lena Headey
saying that Cersei was the 12th person
to finish is probably talking about the
bigger characters in general because not
all the big characters are main
characters they're about 20 big
characters officially though so that
puts her around the middle so big trade
sites were actually reporting which
characters were appearing in how many
episodes and for the most part the
highest-paid actors were appearing in
every single episode
now not all those 20 big characters are
the highest-paid characters you're
talking about Tyrion Jon Snow Daenerys
Cersei Jaime and that wasn't the trade
sites reporting who lives and who dies
that just saying that like a small group
of people were confirmed for every
episode but they didn't know how many
episodes every single character was
appearing in so just because Arya and
Sansa weren't part of that report
doesn't mean anything about when they
may or may not die during the series so
don't look too far into that it just
means that Cersei for sure will be in
that final episode when Lady HEDIS
talking about that special big read
through that they did all the extra
stuff before they started filming most
of that is going to be on the season 8
home video release there'll be a bunch
of bonus features they shot special
documentaries for each of the episodes
for the past couple of seasons it'll be
the same treatment for season aid they
also shot a special episode
with all the biggest characters
including the dead ones like Ned Stark
Robert Baratheon those actors coming
back talking about their characters
reflecting on the series I believe
HBO confirmed that that special episode
would only be available on the blu-ray
home video release and they would not be
airing it on television but have you
seen the promos that I've been posting
for Season eight with each of the single
characters imagine a version of that on
steroids with a bunch of extra footage
it'll probably look something like that
she says she's one of the actors that
likes to screw around a lot between
takes and joke around with the other
actors that's mostly just Lena Headey 's
personality in real life she's super
chill but can you imagine someone trying
to perform Cersei as a method actor
living in Circe's mind for most of the
year they would go crazy so of course
she's gonna joke around between takes
but I love the story she tells when she
says she was trying to duck Dan and Dave
when she knew they were getting ready to
celebrate her final scene of the series
because things had gotten so emotional
and she just felt like she couldn't
handle like okay I'm just gonna duck out
real quick in the catcher on the stairs
like no you are definitely going to
celebrate this moment with us
sophie turner said the same thing about
when she wrapped her final scene of the
series like they basically bring out the
storyboards for their favorite scene of
their character from the entire series
neither one of them sophie Turner Lena
Headey didn't reveal what that favorite
scene was I'm hoping it's something from
season 8 but the look that she gives
Jamie when he says he hates Circe's
character is priceless like what
how dare you say that Cersei is not a
good character the thing is is that
Cersei still is an amazing character she
has her fans but I feel like the noise
from the Jon Snow Daenerys fandom Aria
Sansa some of the other characters just
kind of drowns that out because so much
of the story the last season has been
about Jon Snow Daenerys finally coming
together so let me know in the comments
who is your favorite character going
into the final season of Game of Thrones
and what will happen is is they will
start doing more press for the final
season in the next month or two dan and
Dave confirmed that we'd be getting an
official Game of Thrones Season 8
trailer very soon so when that drops I
will totally do a video for it
congratulations Hendrix Anderson you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Game of Thrones video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here for my Game
of Thrones Season 8 trailer video and
Easter eggs
and click here for my big play
of Game of Thrones Season eight promo
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight